welcome to another episode of not you
deep with me your host grace Helbig this
is a very very very exciting episode
lame or is with us if you don't know her
get ready to fall in love with this lady
she is a comedian she's a musician an
author and all-around just genuinely
wonderful human she does the show tinder
live the tours internationally she has a
book out how to be alone which is
actually fantastic and she's just a real
wonderful person that has feelings and
is a lot like me and it's the first time
we actually got to meet each other so
you're gonna hear a lot of like giggly
new friend banter which is just so cute
so please without further ado I'd enjoy
this episode of not too deep with lame
or this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by OkCupid it's the only
dating app that finds you someone based
on who you are and what you're into
answer front questions and meet someone
who shares your deep love or loathing of
pineapple on pizza or commiserate on
your views of the current state of the
world the OkCupid app has awesome people
like you who are into what you're into
download the free OkCupid app today
[Music]
yay Lane Morris here this is so exciting
yeah okay I gotta jump right into it
because I do when was that podcast Jack
like a year ago that we did this oh my
god so it couldn't have been a year ago
a year ago it was like six months nine
months I was gonna say that sounds about
right because when that all orange
originated was January first I looked
yes okay that's what we were talking
about earlier so I talked about on the
Ashley Perez episode okay so when I was
here on our podcast Jack brought up this
situation that involved you and a man in
the laundry room of your building this
is a saga of sort which sounds more
sexual in that way than it was at all
it's like the most g-rated story but
you're like oh you got kidnapped okay so
explain this story if people don't know
what this is yes please um so uh so what
had happened was I went to go do my
laundry for whatever reason my laundry
wasn't drying um and I I do have laundry
my building I'm blessed in that way
especially for a New York that's that's
already but uh even though like in my
building it's like you have to walk down
these like very narrow steps of this
like creaky terrifies like it looks like
a murder den it's not like I really hope
like people in luxury now Luxor is not
like a luxury building it's not a luxury
laundry room where you're picturing like
that episode of friends or Ross and
Rachel do like it's not like that
it's like really creepy and you're like
am I gonna die down here probably oh
well I've got to do I gotta get clean
underwear yeah what are you gonna do so
um my stuff wasn't drying so I like put
it in for another cycle and just like
kind of kept leaving it and then a
certain point I had to like leave the
house so I left it for longer than I
would and I'd like to say that cuz I'm
not someone who just leaves her laundry
there forever
[ __ ] I'm not an [ __ ] but that
particular day I kind of had to because
it just wasn't it was a lot of blankets
yeah so I went down to go get it and um
I was like oh I went I went to have to
go get it and um all of my laundry had
been perfectly folded on top of the
laundry thing and I live in a small
building where there's not that many
apartments and so I was like and I
before had gone down when I brought my
laundry down I saw this really cute guy
a building and I had just moved in to
the building okay long before and I saw
this cute guy going down to do his
laundry and I was like oh I'm doing my
ladder he's like oh I find it's cool so
this is our meet-cute yeah and I was
like and I thought about tweeting it and
it's so funny cuz with Sony my tweets
that have really blown up I would say
40% of them were things they almost
didn't tweet cuz I'm like maybe that
won't do you have that too you know a
hundred percent things that I'm like
this is so stupid yeah I'm gonna send it
anyway I don't know and then I throw my
phone out the window totally exactly and
then those are always the one not always
but like 40 percent of the time are the
ones that it's like people loved and I
have nowhere yeah and I'm telling this
story now and this because I was like I
like I tweeted about it I was like oh my
god okay like my laundry was in the
dryer for too long cuz I wouldn't try
and now all my stuff is like magically
folded like is this romantic comedy like
what is this cute guy and I don't know
and it was like everyone was like oh my
god and I was like okay people are
interested okay let me do this like an
open like case a cold case yeah totally
exactly people like we need answers yeah
and um so so now he's laundry guy so now
he's laundry guy and so I
went down I was like what am I supposed
to do when it like took a full photo of
like my perfect we need to fold the
clothes and it was funny because people
on Twitter were like they're not that
well for nothing okay well on the floor
do you know what it's like
even though which also not to gender
stereotype could mean more so that a guy
would be the one folding if it's not
folded there well yes that's the
assumption the gross assumption men can
also fold things very well yeah but it's
like I don't it was still very it still
felt like some sort of gesture and I
didn't know yeah what the gesture was
and so I was like should I write a
thank-you note or like a piece of purple
construction paper off and I was just
like thank you and a little lately and I
maybe sign it way and I think and then I
just like left it down there and was
just like oh man it just became like I
was just like I just I didn't even want
to like wear the clothes cuz I was it
just felt like not why is that washer
yeah I feel like a celebrity I don't
know where these now I just want to put
them in glass but then people were like
but he folded your underwear that's
disgusting and I was like I didn't have
that much underwear I was washing he
actually taken those out because they
dry faster and I wanted to focus on the
larger bulk ah yes yes yes I followed
this logic yeah okay so then so then
you're at this impasse of who did this
and you have a notion that laundry
laundry do meanwhile it's like blowing
up the it's blowing the internet and
like the Twitter rom-com invested people
are getting invested it's like all my
childhood crushes like will Friedel's
like oh man I'm like cool like devon
Sawa I'm not even sure if I'm
pronouncing his last name right yeah oh
yeah weirdly Twitter friends now it's
amazing he's like awesome everyone it
was like a who's who of my childhood oh
my gosh we just explored that and so was
Instagram the other day which is a great
he existed it's curious is curious he's
got lots of tattoos now and he's pretty
added yeah yeah yeah and he's like he's
a he's a nice dude every single time I
post laundry guy updates he's like yeah
beautiful world Oh sometimes is
beautiful it's sometimes like honestly
it's like I know that Twitter can be
this like a really dark place but for me
so much of the time like Twitter is this
like wonderful wonderful fantastic so I
yeah okay people are getting involved so
where does it go yeah so I kind of um oh
god it just like where doesn't it go
it's like how much time do we have it oh
good it's been going on don't worry we
have an hour yeah okay okay going since
January and um so because I don't on
going it's so on going so we hung out
the other night and like okay so we
skipped a big chai no we did I just
wanted to like give you a little treat
at that teaser well teaser um you know
where we're going um but uh yeah
basically you know there were a lot of
different there are a lot of different
beats but it's basically um so one day
my dog wanted to UM she wanted to go
outside we have a little backyard area
which is wonderful and there was a girl
who was one of his roommates and I knew
that and I'm we talked for like maybe
like 20 minutes for I was like so um
somebody like folded my laundry the
other night and like if it was like
maybe like one of your roommates and she
got your laundry girl so beautiful so
beautiful
and so uh so what had happened was um I
was like wait what you got and she's
like oh my god we've been trying to
figure out who that was whose clothes
those were and I was like hyper try
figure who blushed oh my god it's just
like it's like well they won't they say
well so um we're talking and um she was
like oh yeah like that was um she's like
yeah that was my roommate like oh my god
this is so funny like he actually asked
me what he should do about it cuz he was
like I went to do my laundry and like
there's some laundry still in the dryer
like I wish I do with it and she was
like just give it a minute like see if
they'll calm you know whatever
he's like okay okay and so then he went
back down he's like it's still there
it's been another hour like shy I don't
know what to do like I really have to
walk to my you know dry my clothes and
she was like okay well you know like
then you take it out I think that's fine
and he was like okay and um and he was
like oh but I don't really know what to
do because like it's like well I found
out what happened later this is all the
information I was given at the time and
then um so he he took it out and I guess
like he came back and he was like I
folded it I don't know if that's weird
that's my ideal Twitter it's just like
he's really pure goofy stories but um uh
he was like a folded it I don't know if
that was weird I felt kind of weird I
just round left her underwear alone I
don't know he really did over the
internet was like what a pervert it was
like no so um and she was like oh we
were all talking about like who's this
girl who is this person whose laundry
was this and I was like it was mine and
then like their other roommate comes out
and um it's like I'm trying ranbir
because like all this was a bit ago yeah
but their other roommate comes out and I
was like hey how's it going and um the
girl turns the other girl and she's like
she's laundry girl and so then I think
the next time I oh oh I so I told her I
was like I was like oh by the way like I
kinda kind cuz you don't need never know
like who's on certain social media and I
was like I was like I'm on Twitter and I
cut into this big thread and it kind of
blew up and it's all about this whole
story and they're like what oh my god
and she was like I can't imagine like a
better person has happened to them like
that dude like he's just such a good
dude and like she's just like what is
this so anyway but then it turned out
that it's like the guy who folded it is
different from the guys on the ha and
it's like so there's like two laundry
guys it's like a while you're sleeping
okay this guy but it's this guy so
they're actually like laundry guys a
laundry boy yeah they're both they're
both they're both laundry guys so um but
yes so the beautiful thing is that I
became friends with all of them and like
we like play board games outside in the
backyard and like you know we I don't
well well well the Hangout and do things
together and it's just wonderful like
that doesn't really happen in New York
where you're like friends your neighbors
are literally like that yeah not oh yeah
the weirdest organically but like yeah
so um and then oh then there were like
all these other things or it was like
before I knew it was him there was we
smelled gas in our apartment and so my
roommate never like do we call the cops
I don't know right and then um and then
uh so we did but then there wasn't like
a problem but I was almost like not
really but like a little hoping that
like there'd be like a building
evacuation I'll be outside and be like
ah ha are you him it was just like oh
maybe like that's what it is um would be
fine and it didn't happen our building
is safe and everyone aside super
annoying for this story for this
plotline exactly exactly where all my
stuff and my loved ones are safe yeah
but at what cost
so then she still don't you had you have
met him at this point I haven't met him
at that point I hadn't when I hadn't run
into his roommates and all of that stuff
but so then the other night I'll give
you like the abridge because should I
just call read the whole threat it's
just it's really just like a thrill a
minute and it updates every few months
it was approved by devon Sawa so what
more do you need to know it's like right
now but I love uh people like we need
more up more regular updates on this
okay I'm like okay I'll try to
manufacture my life why is this like go
ask him out I'm like I live in a small
town I can't if this went awry it's a
high-risk situation yeah yeah no you're
not safe in your own home exactly yeah
thank you thank you so but the other
night we hung out and um all of us cuz
um uh one of the one of the girl
roommates texted me and she was like hey
my friend just read your book she really
loves that she has a note for you that
you want to leave you cuz she's like 90
years old she wrote you like a
handwritten oh so sweet it was really
sweet and I was like beautiful and so I
went down to go pick it up and while I'm
talking to her in walks laundry guy and
the other girl and um and so we all
ended up hanging out and I just like
kept making fun of him and I was just
like I was like why have you done
anything cute in a while you're not
giving me anything to work with the
Internet is waiting
I need you just looked at me like wonder
my salsa too but I was like I don't know
just do something adorable this is
ridiculous I need contact
I need content refused to be inauthentic
about it exactly I was like I'm not
gonna make it up you need to pull your
weight around here I was like what do
you want me to do I was like I don't
know and then you started feeding my dog
cranberries and I was like that'll work
wait have people figured out is he on
social media channel things oh okay
people figured out who he is and started
following him or anything no I don't
think he is cuz they've never said that
but like I did when we weren't hanging
out I was like I was like do you wanna
see the internet freaked the [ __ ] out
writing I was like I'm hanging out with
logic I write it out we're all just like
freaking out everyone's like kids for
them it's like they're they're not super
social media people right which he's
been thrashing and nice totally and I
think that's also the beautiful thing
about this story is it's not like you
know he's not some like super social
media dude so he's just like what yeah
is so exciting yeah there's so there's
such like beautiful kind o people and
they're just so thrilled with that oh
you and then oh god oh god well it was
another one so um I didn't know that
like the girls were on Instagram they
started following me on Instagram and I
followed them back and they created a
thread of like photos my dog and it says
laundry girls and I was like you know
their own personal love stories of how
they met their partners it's this yeah
and he made him into a meme it's really
so wonderful I mean the script writes
itself
you're really good asking for the movie
I really trust me that's that's
something that's that's on the table I'm
ready for ya I've spent my whole life
writing romantic comedies in my head so
like this is I could write this movie in
my sleep and dream project
totally speaking of writing your book
how to be alone yes okay it's out by
determine this packets will come out in
like January so it'll be like a people
will have already read it and every one
of them it's me but you're in the press
stay
right stage right now like going nuts
promoting as1 congratulations it's
number one on Amazon yes it has to be
[ __ ] nuts
it's very cool have you been writing it
for in a lot of ways my whole life I've
always had a folder on my computer that
just said book because there's like I
don't know whatever but I knew and like
there were just so many stories that I
you know I was always I was just always
writing and I I've been writing books
quote-unquote you know since I was a
little kid and was always writing my
stories and just always felt so
fascinated by the world and was just
constant like every job I've ever had
like I spent most of the time writing on
receipt paper or whatever yeah was
always kind of cobbling this together
and then you know then it just kind of
became a situation of what's the book I
want to write and then you know there's
that like weird aspect of like when your
your people are somewhat familiar with
who they know you to be and you're
trying to figure out like okay well who
do you know cuz I knew that like you
know I'd written for the onion and I was
a sex and relationships editor I was
Mona it's like I knew people knew this
side of me but then I was like hmm
I want to like give them that because I
know they like that and I love writing
that however there's also like even when
I was at Cosmo I always joke and by joke
I mean like state of fact that's very
funny which is that the two first
articles that I wrote for Cosmo was one
day to sign me which was 10 fun things
to do with your boobs that one a what
they'd assign me and then the second
order Claire wrote for them was one that
I pitched which was how to talk to a
suicidal friendship yeah I'm just like
sure I'll write like a jokey boob thing
but like look talk about mental health
is that okay yeah I sneak in here and
talk about it so I feel like the book
was kind of that words like okay I want
to like give you like it'll be fun and
it'll be funny and it will talk about
relationships however like I love
exploring deeper aspects of
relationships and I want to talk about
like I've had a really really really
hard life and like where I come from his
has not been which is just awful as the
jokes are I mean that's the thing
because you're talking a lot about
loneliness obviously you're talking a
lot about like your personal stories
yeah and that sort of thing and I love
this thing that you tweeted the other
day about how you keep getting put in a
box of this being a book for Millennials
I thought you know why but it's like
yeah I mean fundamentally I get that
[ __ ] yeah I know I'm alone you know
whatever we all love talking about you
know our feelings online a lot more than
we used to but I love that you like
deflected that and made sure that
everyone knew that this is not me it's
not in my eyes at all yeah I hate
hearing it I hate hearing like I know
I'm not your target audience but I
really loved it I'm like wow it's just
like that like Angry like bear and me
that like wants to be protective right
like how dare you think something's not
for you it is of course it's for you I
hate that you think it's not ya know if
it's if it resonates with you then it's
for you yeah and I can see that like
when you wrote a Cosmo that's obviously
like a targeted demo that they're going
after there and so with your book you
don't want that to be like you know
placed on top of that and you don't want
to like shy anyone away from like that
would venture out not know who you are
and read about something playing you've
been through that resonates with them
and makes them feel like you want less
alone in the world
yeah how has the response been so far
it's been I just got chills because I
started thinking about the response
because I think that sound it's
overwhelming and it's really beautiful
because writing the book like I have no
problem saying it because I this book
almost killed me like many times I was
so painful to write and I didn't have
again like this book I think one thing
that's important to note with this book
and I I try to say a good amount and to
remind people this book was not written
from like someone who's like married now
and now has a wonderful family
I'm not solved I'm not better and I
don't think that that's a sin hmm I
wanted to write a book like that cuz
I've never really seen very many books
that don't end with like and then I met
Jeff and now and shields and I'm like I
don't have a Jeff and even if I met Jeff
I wouldn't be healed
yeah op like I just so but I'm still you
know I wrote it and I didn't have a
really strong support system while I was
writing it and that made it even more
painful because you want to write a book
about loneliness and you want to have
all your friends being like here's some
snacks I know you're really in it but no
I don't have any of that so like yeah
and that sucked and like it was just so
painful and I was just like and then you
cannot so I can see I imagine to how
writing about loneliness because I'm
also working on this book about like
fear it's kind of similar in a way
that's like yeah a more personal side of
me that the internet hasn't really seen
yeah and I'm have
such a hard time starting it because I'm
getting to over an overly analytical in
my brain about like I wanna write
impassioned I wanna write engaging
genuine stories but at the same time
people expect a certain thing and I
don't want them to be like this is like
a real whiny piece of [ __ ] right and so
my idea of writing about being lonely
was there any fear of like people are
gonna read this and say this is a lot
totally and and but this and I even say
it like I you know I what I ended up
doing was like I reference my own fears
in the writing like I think there's a
part in the chapter and I say that
because it's like I went through so many
edits of like should I leave this end
should I not yeah but there's a part in
the first chapter where I was like
there's a part of me that wants to like
throw all of this away and not tell you
this because I don't want you to know
yeah that I've never felt super loved
and I've never felt like I really belong
and like I feel that feels so vulnerable
feels so gross I'm worried you're gonna
judge me but then I think what if you're
sitting there and you feel the exact
same [ __ ] way yeah yeah yeah why am I
looking at this negative way that you're
gonna look at me like what a sad [ __ ] I
think you in some interview saying that
like you wrote the book that you wish
you had read when you were younger
absolutely that's exactly like a really
wonderful like inspiring way to go about
writing I feel I feel like it makes the
book film that much more authentic that
much more real that much more
transparent all of those like buzzy
words that we use but I think that and
it's also like very difficult to do
totally knit to yourself certain
feelings in certain emotion totally and
like it's it feels very like I think
that that's been so but I just kept
telling myself I was like cuz I knew
like like there's always been this voice
deep down that's like guided me and I
can't pin what it is and I don't care
what it is I like that it's in there
yeah but but the one you know the other
was something that when I was writing it
just kept coming into my head and was
just like what you're doing like
everything you think this book is gonna
do like the shift that you think it will
create like the I really wanted it to be
a book but like made everybody feel us
alone many people feel seen in the way
that I'd never felt see him a people
feel less alone in the way that I've
always felt alone made people feel like
they weren't broken in the way that I've
always felt broken like I really
wanted I've always had that about me and
it's yeah it's just it was like kind of
you know I don't wanted to sound cheesy
but it was always kind of like okay I'm
not getting this but like if I can give
it to somebody else like someone's
getting it a little martyr you but like
that's how I feel but it's also not like
a guide it's not like a self-help book
it's literally like this is my
experience like take it early here's
some things I know because I've because
I know I have had a very extreme
experience of being so alone for so long
and then I would run into like the
beautiful thing was while I was writing
it I would get little little reminders
in the world that like you're onto
something because like I met I met this
girl at this event we were at together
and we were like forced to talk to each
other like it's know your neighbor okay
I love people but I'm very socially
anxious like that's the reason why we
started on the Internet it's like
scaring people exactly too many feelings
so um but I was like okay and I was like
I just went on this trip and she was
like I'm gonna like travel you know I
owe you you traveled alone I've always
wanted to try that and I was like I've
only traveled alone and she was like I
just like that's like what and um I was
like oh yeah and she was like oh I don't
know that I could do that and I was like
you've always travel with people and I
was like and it was just like just those
moments when you're like oh [ __ ] like I
really am on the other spectrum but I
have something to offer this person who
wants to travel alone and is scared I'm
like I've only ever I've only ever
traveled alone I don't know what the
other stuff is like but I so I do have
some things to impart but I don't know
it was also like I think it was part of
you know so many years at Cosmo and on
Twitter and people just being like Lane
Morris me like you're exactly say what I
think I'm like were you also a homeless
teen like what are you talking about
but no one knows that they just think
you're this like quirky girl we're just
uh squirty twenty-something goes just
right in my feelings I'm like oh no no
that I'm carrying a tremendous amount of
thing really good at masking it yeah I
mean kudos to me I guess but that's also
probably not healthy then I thought
right but then I was like maybe so is
she
yeah like
that's kind of so fair what I thought so
the the response has been tremendous but
it's been weird because it's just less
like huge outpouring of love and people
like feeling seen and I'm just getting
like all these message every day which I
love but they're like I imagine it's
like Fiona Apple's mailbox you're
getting all these or like Mariska
Hargitay yeah it's just like you're
getting like the most beautiful letters
you've ever read but you're just like
well-intended messages but at the same
time it's like so heavy it's so heavy
and I'm such an empathetic person and
like I want to heal everybody in the
world and I'm just I want to hug
everyone like my friend
I'm staying with an LA like told me last
night she was like she's like dude you
don't even need to tell me that you're
like giving too much to everything you
can't write back to like 200 emails a
day with like i'm passioned and like
when i sign books like the books I think
I've done so far I've just like they'll
pour their stories out and then I'll
write and then I'll write what I think
they most want to hear maybe the most
healing and then by the time I'm done
I'm like I think I'm dying
because you can't give that it's so
taxing emotionally and I think I want
thing is that you're a good person and
that's why you have those feelings I
think it's also like a developmental
thing and I struggle with this I totally
get it
so much where it's like I never want to
not give someone the time that they
deserve or that matters to me that
they're reading myself and they love my
supp and like I'm writing for them like
that's why that's what got me through
this was the idea that you have one
person would read this book and be like
I feel somewhat heals like so the fact
that there's like hundreds and hundreds
of people and I I love one girl wrote me
the other day and she was like I'm sure
you have someone else who reads all your
emails and I was like I don't have a bed
frame like you think other things than
what our true well I replied and within
five minutes like I'm around you know
I'm the other end she's like what
exactly she was behind totally but it's
like to me you know whatever
okay we're gonna take a really quick
break and we get back I have a billion
more questions this could be a six-hour
podcast
[Music]
hey grace guess what what this episode
of not too deep is brought to you by her
buddies an OkCupid oh this is really fun
guys if you don't know what OkCupid is
it's the only dating app that finds you
someone based on who you are and what
you're actually into yes the OkCupid
dating app asks you fun and meaningful
questions that matter to you so that you
can be seen by people who are going to
be into you because why waste your time
you got to get specific you want to ask
people questions like Trump question
mark questions like is die hard a
Christmas movie sure do you want to ask
someone what their favorite podcasts is
I think that's a great conversation
starter yeah do you think cilantro
tastes like soap or not don't get me
started you'll see tons of answers that
lead to great conversations and great
dates with people who feel the same way
that you do tell people about your
favorite album your last great trip or
your favorite podcasts for instance and
let the love roll in on the OkCupid app
whether you're looking for that person
to join you on a long walk on the beach
or short walk to the bar they're waiting
for you on the OkCupid app so start the
new year by meeting someone who's into
what you're into on the okay keep it at
download the free OkCupid app and find
your next great date today we're back
alright okay let's talk about tinder
lives yeah this is your live show that
you do in New York yes it started in
2014 yes correct
okay so take me through this how did
this start yeah so I created tinder
lives literally the second that I went
on tinder for the first time like I
think people think that I was like on
tinder for like a long time before it no
no it was literally what happened was I
I tell this story like it's me meeting
the love of my life I'm just like oh
early 2014 but I came out of my room in
my apartment at the time I had two
roommates a guy and a girl and they were
both sitting at the kitchen table on
tinder together at the same time and I
was like this app is just you're both on
it you don't know you're both on it like
it's just that Tinder's like peak where
everyone was on it yeah and so I was
like all right screw it I'm in and so I
downloaded tinder and like a few swipes
and I was like do you guys mind if I
like grab my laptop and like record this
like videotape this and so I you know
recorded us going on tinder live
together and just like talking about
profiles at a roundtable and in that
same like I was like I'm gonna edit this
together I'm like put it online it's
like a comedy baby this is so funny this
is so good and a few swipes in I was
like this could be a comedy show like I
could project my my tinder on like a big
screen I could go through it live I
could have like a panel of like other
comedians or you know actors musicians
whatever just like funny people it could
be a mixture of people the audience
could like vote whether I swipe right or
left it's like super interactive and
like fun yeah sorry like going to
different segments that I could do like
I have a bit that I do called which one
is it which is when like the photo of
the 30 people like this might be my kid
or like look I have a mom I must be a
good man like just like that and I I
went and worked on the show that same
night and pitch at that same night it
was just like the night I got a tear it
was like my whole life exploded and in
the best way and um my for the first
show I didn't really tell anybody about
and really know how to go about it um
first I was actually at the pit yeah oh
really um yeah and it was like half sold
out and I was like huh
and then the next show was sold out and
I was just like what is this and like I
remember the front like again we had not
said anything about it but I remember
the second show that I did like a few
weeks later all these people were like
messaging me and they were like dude my
whole office is like coming here sure
like all these people were like
everyone's talking about it and I was
like amazing and then you know it just
grew and grew and grew and like now I
tour the world with it and it's like I
love doing it what are have you had I'm
sure you've had some follow up scenarios
that were not ideal are there any like
oh god we did something bad during the
show like
following up with you that you swiped on
or that Oh like after the show kind of
thing yeah um you know what uh not
really I mean I think so the thing is
because it's like we're people who
haven't seen the show it's like I know
sometimes what they're thinking in their
head is that they're thinking that it's
gonna be mean and it's one of the things
I'm really protective about is how kind
it is and I really love that in like
every single like it's been written up
by the New York Times by all these in
places they always mention that it's
such a kind show that genuine show it's
a genuine show it's not a like look at
this idiot
yeah peaceably not roasting every person
no coming across that's not money that's
not my vibe at all I don't think that's
funny I think that that's not great but
you know it really is just like I'm
playing a character of like this super
goofy girl who's just like maybe on like
a lot of ecstasy and it's like pretty
dumb like that's like what it is like
I'll just like tell guys like he hasn't
got like okay here's a good example but
I like to give of a recent recent
scenario so a guy came up when I tender
live show in New York City and his
profile said I bet I love anime way more
than you and I was like oh that's a
swipe right that's a tender live like
that to be talked to 100 I was like that
dude that you'd be like oh that's a
little much like that so I want to talk
to him tender life that's what you
matched and I was like what enemy and he
wrote back and he was like lol and I was
like what's funny I don't know it's like
a form of animation and they sent him a
gift from the Aristocats and I was like
isn't that and I was like I'm so sorry
I'm just like so horny and naked I'm so
confused
like it's just like a weird combination
of like she's down to [ __ ] but she's not
the smartest and guys love her and so he
was just like haha and he was like no
that's not it and I was like okay and
he's like where do you live and I was
like one two one one anime Avenue he was
like I was like I don't get it
like what like just like this incredibly
is so confusing for the person on the
other end that's confusing but they
don't want ya it's like you guys are
just like sure but it's less like I was
like I just basically give them or there
was like a guy once who said like you
know if you're if you're uh he said if
you're a feminist don't message me but
feminist wasn't spelled Oh like it or oh
no wait was it Oh what was I know what
it was it was like if you're a feminist
swipe you know swipe laughs I don't want
to talk to you and um and I was like oh
I'm swiping right like that's to talk to
her life so we met we messaged and I was
like what's that feminists I don't know
what a feminist is and I was like but
they sound awful I'm not like that I'm
cool he wrote back and he was like he
was like Oh feminism and he'll expelled
it right this time he was like oh he's
like feminism and I [ __ ] you know this
is literally what he wrote feminism is
women who believe in equality among the
genres not genders genres and I was like
I was like oh you mean like sci-fi is as
good as [ __ ] cuz I don't agree he was
like no like like what you know like but
we talked for like an hour but that's
like what gender life is so it's very
like good nature and it's very silly but
so nine times out of 10 these guys are
laughing along with me like that Anna my
guy was just like yeah it's like cuz
it's just so funny so if anything I've
had the reverse happen which is there
was a guy who came up I did a show in
Minneapolis and he came up on the show
and he was this really like 70s looking
dude and he had these great bell-bottoms
and so I sent the whole show trying to
steal his jeans like just like can we
meet up what's your waistband side and
I'm just asking huh my boobs like
whatever keep them interested and he was
just like at a certain point the show
he's like stop try to steal my jeans
these are expensive but I was like I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry okay well like
what are your hobbies when I was like in
your pants and so um after the show I
was like hey I was near a with you I did
this show called tinder live like you
were so funny and you were such a like
good dude you just seemed really cool
and he was like what I knew something
was a little bit up but I didn't mind
cuz you're weird I'm weird and I was
like oh that's sweet so we like became
Instagram friends and we like he would
like ask me about girl a girl advice and
I would ask him about
and then he came into town recently and
he was like hey my bands in town do you
want to come hang out and we hung out so
like yeah I was like okay I was gonna
say do you ever follow up and let them
know like this is kind of like if they
seem really cool like yeah they're
really cool I'm just like just FYI like
you know you were on this show like you
should come to the show sometime and um
like and again it's like they're like
okay and like sometimes people are or
sometimes their friends will talk about
me like do join tendril Ivan Belt
message me Lily
that's so cool is there video cuz they
oh yeah no it's not mean-spirited it's
it's this like it's fun it's fun and
people are usually on the side of the
guys like we've had shows why people
were so rooting for this guy cuz he was
being so funny to what I would say like
I'm so weird I mean they handle it
really well they like our you know
respectful totally and they're just
they're throwing jokes back to you like
that's the best tinder live moment where
I get some jam and they're throwing the
ball back and they're having fun and
they're just like who is this angel
invite like I invited one of the guys to
the show I did in Baltimore not long ago
and everyone like cheered his name we
sent him a wee text that because I told
him he was on the show and I was like I
never do this mid show cuz it could go
anyway I was like put your on right now
I'm like will you come down to this
venue and anyone ever been in the venue
or they have only once but it's like
whenever somebody's profile comes up and
they're in the venue like I usually just
ask them like what their tender
experience is like and kind of like
maybe you know maybe we'll show their
profile on screen if they if they want
to or whatever oh actually there was a
really good I did a show at University
of New Hampshire not long ago and there
was this profile that came up and I
always tell people like if this is your
profile like let me know I'll be really
ask to you and um and this guy was like
those well who's my profile and I was
like oh really like cuz everyone sheer
knows like oh you must be here cool I
was like do you mind if we like look at
your profile like you know looking us up
he was like yeah I guess so and I was
like okay we go through it's this long
rap this look really long run and it
ends with like I'm with the girl in the
photos I'm just you're pretender live
and everyone [ __ ] lost it because I
read it line my line so it I didn't know
and that ever was just like oh my god
all his friends knew he'd made the
profile specifically for dinner like he
had a drag
and it's just praying it would come up
and it was like I wanted to stop the
show I was like what better ending could
be happy yeah like it was so golden I
laugh until I couldn't breathe that I
was literally just like I haven't I have
not yet won like a major award but I
think it feels like this like just like
this is so like just she made that he
like stood up and was like looked around
all other kids at the college it was
like you're welcome you're like and he
like was this like little celebrity at
that point yeah but dude can get it like
so it's that kind of show which is great
because you do tender live do people do
people come to the show because they
want to date you know like you get that
sort of kind of attention it's rude but
I don't I think it's I think there's a
level of intimidation because it's like
I I don't know I think there might be
some of that the alternative that if you
meet someone they are like nervous about
the idea that your world is kind of
wrapped up in this app maybe so like
okay so recently I matched when I was
doing tinder on my own time and I met
the sky and I he messaged me and I I put
in my profile like I do this show
cult-like like here are some things I
want in like a person or better yet like
just come to the next tender live show
bring flowers if that would be ideal
yeah do you put this do you like
broadcasting yeah I'm just like you know
I'm just gonna start saying it like it's
it's fine I've had people super like man
gender cuz they were like no but for
real do you want to go out like oh okay
well I don't know but uh so but this guy
um we messaged really two messages and
then he was like yo all of my female
friends just flipped the [ __ ] out that
we match that I match with you like he's
like I'm not really online but like I
guess like they follow you on twitter
like they've seen tinder live and like
I'm tender live right now cuz I'm
freaked out and I was like first of all
you would have no reason to freak out if
you were on general life second of all
you wish you weren't like I was like you
which that's what that would be great
for you you wouldn't love it like so
this idea that like it was like no but
I'm also a person I'm like this is this
started because I genuinely started
because I wanted to meet people you know
I'm also a person he was like okay I'm
nervous I'm like wait but I'm not like a
mean but you have clearly haven't seen
the show yeah don't know that like I'm
not messing with you also like the show
is not me taking like men who genuinely
want to date me being like help me get
away from me you attractive idiot like
no no I would love to find that but it's
just like not yet okay let's talk about
your dog like I miss her a little face
yeah what kind of she's a little thing
she is a little thing what kind of dog
is she
um she's a chihuahua but I feel like she
is some she's mixed with something else
but I don't know she's a rescue so she's
a cutie she is thank you how long have
you had her um I've had lights not even
a year yet not even a year but you
wouldn't know it from our paw who or
what is lights worst enemy or nemesis
people she feels are a threat to me
she's protected she's sober which I love
because I've never really had that and
it's like she's so like it's so good
like even we're in the backyard and like
the laundry girls are there that's what
I'm gonna call them now um you want to
we're in the backyard and like she knows
them and they're so sweet to her and
they've given her snacks but like if
they even like look at me in a way that
she does not like she's like like it's
just like don't worry my mom my mom's
book for his daughter and like when
people have come over to my apartment
before like who I didn't know very well
like for whatever various reasons and um
when they come over like if they have
like a weird vibe and I'm feeling where
like she was be like I don't like you oh
you're making my mom and comfortable I
can tell and I like that's the craziest
thing how I pick up on your like
sub-conscience itch I love like I did a
podcast taping in my apartment last
weekend I was really like I was having a
hard day and like I was just wasn't
ready to talk about a lot of things we
were talking about I was really
uncomfortable and she shook the entire
time and it's like
it's kind of it's sad but then you're
just like whoa you're like this
incredible mirror like our mind like
I've got to take care of myself because
it's affecting you yeah and you know so
amazing how much they recognize it and
you don't even know cuz I was like I got
this she was just like no we're not so
it's it's beautiful but yeah I feel like
it's it's it's it's nice I don't know
she's but she's very protective which I
like she's a cutie okay if you could
cure a any kind of University class
speaking of just being at a college and
you were me you'd be the professor what
sort of class would you create something
centered around feelings and empathy and
how to [ __ ] have it yeah I think
that's so upsetting how few people have
empathy and like know how to lay shock
it's really upsetting to me like that
honestly that was a big part of how to
be alone is being like like I got a
question recently from somebody who was
like at one of the books I love the
question and I was likes anyone have any
questions about the book and the guy was
like do you have any tips for like I've
had a really like easy life like my
life's are pretty great and then I don't
know how to respond to friends like when
they're going through really intense
stuff I have no idea what they're saying
and I was like I love that you asked
that question and I think you're a good
person yeah because I think there are
people who just like empathy I think for
the most part you develop it through
your own pain and through your own
struggles and so if you haven't had that
like good for you but the one thing
you're missing is empathy and it's so
it's just very painful I think for me to
deal with people where you're just like
oh you don't you don't care like I once
I once had a drummer who was like yeah I
don't really have they don't really care
when people are in pain I just like it
doesn't affect me and I was like how are
we in a band together I hate it yeah you
won't last long I will replace you this
hurts yeah it blows my [ __ ] mind when
someone feels nothing for someone that's
feeling so many things I feel everything
like I feel like people on the subway
when they're sad I'm like homely like
you're in pain you can't help ever
believe I've got that just like I'm
gonna give her my flowers I'm gonna give
her my flowers so what you and I
reowww and do you think it can be taught
cuz that's I always get so I mean I've
dated people before that lacked a
certain sense of empathy and in my brain
stayed with them forever because I
figured they're gonna eventually figure
this out they're gonna develop it and
it's also so gendered to where it's like
I know so and my female friends who it's
like are trying to and I'm not saying
it's like obviously the other men you
have a lot of empathy and they're women
who don't have that the fee and it's not
gendered however I do know a lot of my
female friends who have dated men who
just like don't seem to care about
anyone's feelings at all and they're
trying to like put them through their
own university program and I'm like
that's just like this unbeaten ocean
labor that like women are told that like
well men don't have any feelings and
they shouldn't have to and we should
build feelings for and like yeah so we
can fix them change them mold them I'm
so tired I don't want I don't want that
I just know yeah I do think though that
people like that guy that I asked you
that question that they're genuinely
curious right now it can develop it out
of that curiosity develop but it's
sometimes it can reach it can reach an
impasse like you know it was a guy who I
met on tinder and like we had this
really like lovely kind of courtship and
he'd had a really really easy life but
he had a really solid like there was
some really solid empathy there and I
really loved it because it was perfect
for me because it was like oh you have a
secure attachment style
you're you that's this will be great for
me who does not like you come from a
good family
I don't look great great so but then I
realized that like his empathy like hit
a wall like you know what I mean where
it's just like you're like oh hey this
feeling I guess what it is I was like oh
that's all you have and then there were
certain ways to communicate it
communicated we're like and I've had
this happen before where it's like and
there's a guy in the book where you talk
about the sport was like every time I
would be like will you hurt my feelings
then he'd be like well I didn't mean it
so move on are we done and you're like
no yeah how do you a friend it's like
the it's it's I don't know how to
describe other than like the ability to
compartmentalize things and just like
push things away with no like curiosity
of like living in there and exploring
what's going on and no sense of like
responsibility like I feel a sense of
responsibility to
people I don't want to like keep other
people safe and happy and ask and it's
exhausting huh-huh
but I don't understand like I always
said that I think there's a happy medium
between like guy who has like no empathy
and me who has like way too much and
it's like crippling at times like I
think the the healthy thing is in here I
don't think that mine's healthy I don't
think this is healthy right right right
but I think it should be to where like
you know you're you're you mess yourself
first right you're not empathetic in a
way you're not overly empathetic in the
way that it wears on you emotionally and
like hurts you yeah in the roundabout of
it all mm-hmm yeah well something that's
still figure out okay no work on back we
have Twitter questions for you yeah hey
grace what's up Jack do you have any New
Year's resolutions
I am so resolute in hoping that these
beautiful listeners have not too deep
might perhaps go on to the iTunes Apple
podcasting situation and leave us a
review yes that is exactly what I was
leading to thank you for taking me there
yep yes guys we don't make this plea
very often but we do from time to time
that is it yes that is the way we're
helping the podcast grow and in 2019
that we want not too deep to be the
biggest it's ever been and the way for
that to happen is if we can get new
listeners so if you have friends who
like funny things you should recommend
our podcast to them in addition to that
the best way to reach new people is for
us to appear on the charts on the Apple
podcast app and the iTunes Store and the
best way for us to get those chart
possibilities is for you guys to leave
us a review we do read them we do
honestly and we do appreciate that I
don't get thrown into the internet ether
they get thrown in front of our faces in
front of our laptops that's right and
and you know as you guys know the format
of this show has grown and evolved over
the years it's matured it has and I like
to think so
and you know it's it's important for us
to check in with you guys and that's the
best way for us and if you already
after review before in the years past
now that we've matured and grown and
become sort of different you know shades
of the podcasts leave another one yeah
hopefully we can make a bunch of spambot
accounts spam us with your reviews I
dare you I do this is now a threat and I
dare you if you're a hacker who can like
launch a malware attack and make
millions as well now you've gone too far
we would love any support from you guys
it's been fun to create this and we want
to keep doing it we want new eyes on it
so leave us a review if you feel so
inclined thanks guys okay yeah we do I'm
gonna ask you the two questions asked
every single guest that's on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
[Laughter]
okay I know who it is and I feel bad
because I don't like I don't like the
idea of throwing spaghetti a woman all
right Yolanda Saldivar I [ __ ] miss
alline every single day I am obsessed
Alina I think she is still the queen of
Tejano music I love her so much I was so
devastated when she died
Yolanda you killed her don't tell me
there was misunderstanding
well I can safely say we have never
received your so to the captivating
why does okay the other question is to
tell us your worst pants [ __ ] story
or close call but you can only use three
words or three small phrases or some
mixture of the two so mine is college
jogging front lawn it can be a close
call I was gonna say cuz I can't I
remember like I have a lot of weird
pooping stories sure but not okay
I'll do it my own way okay yeah god I'll
do my own spin like a bathtub laughter
depression yeah wouldn't don't blame you
okay let's these Twitter questions let's
jump into these real quick some once
know how his lights doing she's okay so
she need to travel with you she does
sometimes this time because as everybody
knows first-time authors makes so much
money I'm sleeping on a couch so my
friend can't have dogs in her building
and so she couldn't home with me but I
promised her like the other night before
I left town I was like I'm never gonna
do this to you again cuz she has a
really hard time when we're not together
and so do I yeah but um she's doing okay
she just got a ton of teeth bowl because
she's still on like it's late meds so
many payment she got 16 teeth pulled
Oh baby that's so funny my friend mamrie
or her dog beans who's a Mexican solo or
something yeah got all of her teeth
place is also for Mexico or something
happening yeah it's so nuts where they
just rotting teeth yeah beans yeah it
was like she just had a rough little
little life but my roommate sent me a
photo of her and I wish she had it
because whenever I'm not there she looks
like she's ready for Jess yeah it's like
she's literally known as lights of
smiling chihuahua but when I'm not there
she's looks like this oh I know it's
like if you're listening this you can't
see it but just the picture like the
most depressed you've ever seen a dog
look do like this status is the white
worth like uncomfortable for you to see
it makes me sad too but I'm like I'll be
back soon I set up a whole little thing
I was like this is your fuzzy blanket I
have this little stuffed squirrel from
the 60s I'm like look squirrels here I'd
like try to make it okay so once know as
Stevie Nicks the best thing to ever
happen to us as humans are you you're in
a band yeah yeah yeah called it was
romance um yeah our next album is coming
out a couple months this will be great
that's like it's so cool that's good
how many albums have you guys named um
we have one album that's out yeah it was
unlike pitchforks like albums to watch
and like all the things good
cool good stuff I'm really excited to
put out more music yeah that I'm even
must be nice to be able to have that
balance of all these different artistic
expressions going on it's all I've ever
wanted to do a MIDI band or anything
right like not at all how do you
describe music yeah I think it's like
it's like Stevie Nicks Fiona Apple with
elements of like Ellie Goulding's SIA
stuff like oh and the next album is very
like Ellie Goulding's yeah lights some
Amy Winehouse he stuff so yeah whoa that
sounds does awesome yeah how did that go
yeah I've been I've been making music
since I was a little kid and I always
wanted to be like from birth was like I
want to be an actress writer singer you
know funny writer or whatever like
didn't know what a comedian was I don't
think I want to be Lucille Ball she's an
extra I was like no you want to be a
comedian yeah yeah but and was like
obsessive stand-up it was like no no
funny actress and I was like I was
liking it too like not knowing I was gay
good night no it's like comedian no I'm
a funny actress comedian no no I've
never been attracted to company articles
but yeah and so then I started putting
out my own music where I was like
playing all the instruments as it was
romance and then found like the band
mates of my dreams and then it took
years and was finally able to like put
the album out and like you know I like
produced it and mixed and mastered it
myself it was like all this very like we
don't have money but I know these songs
are great and so this next record is
gonna be so fun because um we went to
record it and Nashville and like have
like an actual producer who's like great
and it's gonna be like I like to make
like happy songs for sad people like
that's like I feel like my line yeah I
think that's it or it's like I want like
songs about suicidal ideation you can
dance to
that's what this record is gonna be
that's my [ __ ] so yeah I'm very obsessed
with Stevie Nicks very obsessed she once
held both of my hands like it was like
after the show and like I ran up to the
stage and she shook everyone's
individual hand but took both of mine
who do I feel like I've been blessed yes
I'm pretty sure she's my mom and it's
fine but like literally one of my wife
goals is to play Stevie Nicks in movie
one day like I feel like I can do it and
I do a great cbx like I got I feel like
you we we often like to manifest guests
destinies here on the podcast is part
the secret I want multiple Grammys I
want to I want to II got within the next
three years I owe and love but it's like
low on the list because I don't you get
it it's like yeah just like career is
good enough supported will see just make
out with my Oscars I don't need this
what is your stance on big butts and
don't lie I have one that's true okay so
let's know what do you think you'd be
doing if you didn't have the career you
have now I'm under the ground dead but
I'm like I would be dead because this
has been like my career is like also
survival like that's how I've like made
it through yeah yeah I know and people
ask that question a lot like if money
were no option and you the entertainment
and we're no option yes if you could
make money doing whatever it is that you
wanted to do I see okay yeah the
entertainment industry wasn't an option
what would you do and I don't even know
the answer for myself I go and travel
blogger again this is all I've ever
wanted is everything I've ever thought
about since I was born like I just I
can't
there's no I'm not that person like
every now and again like I'll read an
interview with like Adele or something
and she's like I hate this I don't even
want to do this I just want to be a bob
and like good go to it what's happening
because this is all I will this is what
I love is Miami
I can't even yeah dead because he's dead
all right
doesn't pay much but someone says
introduce yourself in three words oh I
feel like this is gonna just gonna sound
a little bit live laugh love or
something but um um feelings humour
music that's what I'm gonna do oh that's
cute yeah I feel like that's what I boil
down to that's for sure good yeah okay
the last question and I'm real light
what is the meaning of life and yet I
still didn't look as sad as what I
mentioned Yolanda Saldivar peak
emotional expression really didn't
really really targeted I think deep
within my deeper than my selena obsessed
soul oh okay in front of Kendall's okay
the meaning of life
okay this is like how about this yeah
what's a solid piece of life advice I'm
sure that people could get out of your
book but something that if someone came
up to you it's like would your go-to
thing to say to someone honestly it
sounds simple but I think I would say
and the thing that I try to encourage
people to do in everything I make is
like just be kinder than even you think
you need to be like truly truly because
I think the people who do that are just
it's you change you'd really change
people's lives like you really don't
know what someone's going through and I
you just just like acknowledging someone
or a smile could change the entire
course of that absolutely like so much
of so much of the things that I've
gotten through life we're absolutely I
feel like I remember everybody who liked
it even the littlest things for me
because they've got me through that and
I you know I'm very like give it back
again to an exhausting degree but like
someone will smile at me when I had a
hard day and I'm just like dear whoever
is potentially listening make sure that
they get a million dollars and have them
feel so loved the rest of their day
because they made me feel loved and I
want that and I'm like oh my god but
it's but it's like but I know it means
that much to me so yeah no that's a
great that's a great piece of advice
Lane thank you so much
thank you fine before you go we're gonna
give you the partying if we give
everyone for being on the podcast as you
get a personalized fortune cookie just
for you open of course you can many many
people are impatiently waiting with
popcorn and tissues for the laundry guy
rom-com please when is the release date
to that I would say in the spirit of
manifesting give me a giant pile of
money in the studio so I can make it oh
right the [ __ ] out of it it's great and
Lane where can people find a thing
you've already written the book how to
be alone and that we can't find you if
they don't already know
absolutely um so how to be alone if you
want to and even if you don't is on it's
literally everywhere so it's on Amazon
and there's an audiobook version there's
an audio book as well which is so fun
cuz I do accents and impressions and I
sing and it's like I play the intro and
the outro on guitar and like it's it's
great that's amazing um so yeah so
please go buy that especially like local
bookstore is always lovely to support on
Twitter and Instagram
hello lean more there's also a at tinder
live Instagram and if you want to follow
my dog she's like the smilin Chihuahua
and she's like a giant pile of happiness
oh that's so great oh yeah and my band
is it was romance band perfect yeah
thank you again so much please go buy
the book go read it or listen to it
whatever's easiest for you do both you
both read along goodbye - deep deep deep
not too deep as a production of grace
Helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack Fairy producer and
editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane King
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]